bon alors jean marie bigard tu viens de
te marier ouais là raconte tout ça bah
je me suis mariée alors ça va grand la
grande surprise c'est que je m'aperçois
que je me suis marié avec la femme de ma
vie
ah bon c'est tenir c'est un coup de bol
et puis plus est bien plus plus j'aime
ma femme à rejeter tout le monde va dire
attends il est à six mois ouais non non
mais ça fait deux ans qu'on se connaît
mais je crois que leur part nous est
très bonne chose
le viano raconte la plus belle femme de
la terre est j'adore aller à la tout
compris est intelligente sait tout faire
ah bon elle est remerciée résille est la
moitié américaine
c'est une grande celle qui l'a dit c'est
vrai quand cité mariale église oui j'ai
été laissé la baie les troncs qui nous a
il s'appelle comment la bei s'appelle la
belle et ronces et lemonnier des
artistes ça tombait bien parce que
chacun sa croix
cette fille claudia quand vous êtes
mariés à l'église que tu l'as vu arriver
dans sa robe blanche
ouais tu as dit j'ai failli m'évanouir h
et jura bon bah oui mais tu te rends
compte de temps faut que je t'explique
quand même si c'est que depuis l'âge de
16 17 ans comme ça c'est
au brésil la robe de mariée à les
fabriquer c'était une robe de mariée
fabriqué à la main avec des petites
perles cousue partout et elle était
belle comme le jour et j'ai vu arriver
parce qu'elle s'était évidemment cachée
de moi toute la matinée et que j'ai vu
arriver dans l'église c'est vrai que ça
m'a fait vraiment un coup est ce que tu
es de fidèles oui tu dis ça parce
qu'elle regarde la télé là non non non
si tu l'a trompée est-ce que tu mettrais
des préservatifs
j'en mettrais bien sûr d'ailleurs nous
avant de se marier on est à être dépassé
à la gamelle oui mais elle est
régulièrement parce que je crois que
c'est vachement important de se
contrôler quand j'entends des gens moi
qui disais ah non moi je payet ou moi je
préfère pas savoir ouais ceux là sont
vraiment des [ __ ] vraiment ouais tu
commentes que tu sais pas si tu as une
casquette ou un revolver dans le slip il
faut le savoir
donc là moi j'ai envie de les dire à
tout le monde il faut se contrôler tous
les pays bas du lait mais qui tire à
droite à gauche doivent se contrôler
tous les six mois
voilà les bagnoles